Len Downey jr. co-author of the book the
news about the news but what got you
interested in doing a book well I've
spent 37 years of my life working in the
news business at the Washington Post and
in recent years had been accumulating
material about the business because I
could tell we're coming to a crossroads
with changes in ownership changes in
technology changes in cultures and it
turned out that Bob Kaiser who used to
work with me as managing editor the post
and is now an associated in the paper
had been thinking along the same lines
and brought it up one day said he wanted
to write a book about this subject I
said well so do i and we teamed up how
did you go about it we we combined
research material which we both have
cumulated a lot of files and then we
divided up how we were going to do the
reporting and he focused on network news
although the two of us interviewed to
all the three I wouldn't network anchors
together which was great fun and we
focused together on newspapers obviously
subject we know well we interviewed a
lot of editors and newspapers across the
country and then I looked at local
television news going to stations around
the country watching how local
television news is actually made coming
to understand that business and also on
internet news from your perspective
what's the most important thing that you
found after doing all that research I
think there were a really critical time
in the news business in this country and
that American people ought to know that
and I understand why and ought to help
make the things go in the right
direction in in one way this is the best
type for news ever the best news
organizations are better than ever the
people who work for them are better
educated better trained more expert in
the things they cover and thanks to the
internet research can go more deeply and
further around the world than ever
before and the best news organizations
can be disseminated on the Internet
around the world that's the washington
post this for example in the New York
Times and CNN and so on but at the same
time too many news organizations in fact
more all the time in newspapers that
networks themselves and local television
stations the news is getting worse
rather than better because of changes in
ownership and that to created these
large conglomerates that owned many
newspapers most newspapers now and TV
stations and the networks themselves who
don't care as much about news as they do
about their next quarterly profits and
also changes in the American culture
where until before September 11th we've
gone through a long period where I think
people felt pretty comfortable good
times economically before the recession
and relative peace before September 11th
and at least the people who run news
organizations thought to people weren't
so much interested in serious news
anymore and so celebrities and kind of
light things became covered more than
serious news can you remember your first
newspaper my first newspapers you ever
read oh then I ever read yes it was the
Cleveland Press in Cleveland Ohio and
the Cleveland Plain Dealer how old were
you oh I was probably around nine ten
because in elementary school I was
fortunate to have an English teacher who
started a student whose paper when I was
in the fifth grade and I started working
on that and thought this was the
greatest thing in the world so I began
reading the Cleveland newspapers more
carefully as a result and I started
carrying there was a newspaper carrier
why did you think it was the greatest
thing in the world that's hard to say
I've just enjoyed it so much since I was
10 11 years old I guess partly is the
sense of public service even in school
that you're telling other people
something that they want to know you
might be making their lives better
through the information that you're
giving them but also the Variax of
reporting writing and editing or just
great fun to make it said it's a craft
what kind of a family did you grow up in
a family of four sons I'm the oldest my
father was a salesperson I guess he
started as a milkman first but wound up
being a vice president sales of a number
of companies in the food business my
mother was a stay-at-home mother and
coping with these for formal ways and
for my parents I know that I've gotten a
really strong sense of honesty and
service they are they're wonderful
examples to me that way why it's just
why you remember for instance though
when I was there I don't know eight nine
ten years old I'd gone to the store
around the corner for my mother and they
had given me the wrong change which I
didn't know until I gotten home my
mother was very careful with money and
she counted the change and realized they
gave me five dollars extra and sent me
straight back to the store to return
that five dollars for example how were
you when that happened oh eight or nine
years old now what about the family the
other three brothers did they get in
this business no no I'm the only one my
dad would have been a newspaper man if
it
for the depression I'm certain he worked
in his high school newspaper in
Cleveland Ohio he contributed poems and
stories to the local newspapers there
but the depression came along he
couldn't go to college here to go right
to work and he's always loved writing
sales talks and things ever since he
might have been in the business but my
brothers are ones a labor lawyer and
actually well excuse me a labor
executive not a labor lawyer and am in a
steel company and my next brother runs
the restaurants and unfortunately my
youngest brother who was a very
dedicated school teacher died a few
years ago of liver problems where did
you go to college ohio state university
because they gave me lots of scholarship
money to study journalism there and
enabled me to work at the university and
elsewhere around columbus ohio get me
cept myself through school I was the
first in my family to go to college how
was it that you got the scholarship
money I was a competition actually the
Cleveland Ohio newspapers then they
don't do this anymore along with the
Board of Education had a scholarship
competition for high school journalists
they would pick the most what they felt
was the most outstanding high school
journalist and they got a scholarship to
Ohio State University that paid all the
tuition not the room and board but the
tuition when you think back on a high
estate and journalism what did it teach
you we had a very realistic student
newspaper there called the lantern and
published five days a week 30,000 copies
every day because of the size of the
Ohio State campus late deadlines just
like a regular morning newspaper would
close the paper at one o'clock at night
and that experience was invaluable doing
real journalism on a campus we also had
a faculty it included a lot of X news
men and even some people that worked in
newspapers working the faculty for a
while went back to newspapers so the
instruction was very realistic and the
man who was then the director of the
school of journalism the late George
kinzel is the person that filed me my
summer internship job at the Washington
Post so I'm very grateful to Ohio State
what year was that that was in 1964 have
you ever worked at another newspaper not
not professionally now so what makes a
great newspaper a great owner first of
all an owner dedicated the public
service in addition the profitability as
the Graham family has been all along
when they own the newspaper outright and
now that they have the controlling
shares in a public corporation
a set of news values that is shared in
this organization being dedicated to
outstanding coverage into community
service and talent which which the
owners have to pay for as you try to
hire the best and brightest people who
can achieve the news values of the
organization how many great newspapers
are they in the United States oh I hate
to put an exact number on it but we can
name a number right now certainly the
New York Times The Wall Street Journal
and I like to think the Washington Post
the Los Angeles Times is rapidly
improving again under new ownership and
with an outstanding new editor and
managing editor there are smaller
newspapers that do really good good work
in the book we talk about the Raleigh
News & Observer for example the
newspapers across the country owned by
families name i'm forgetting at the
moment are improving the the news and
observer is owned by Micucci i think
they're recently bought by McClatchy
McClatchy is a very good honor they also
in the newspapers in california and they
recently bought the newspaper in
minneapolis as well and they improve
newspapers when they buy them unlike
some large chains where the newspapers
don't get improved when they're when
they're bought instead they're squeezed
for maximum profits and their journalism
and gets worse family's name was trying
to remember was the new house family who
owned number of newspapers across the
country for many years that were
relatively mediocre and something went
on inside that family generational
change or whatever but they have
dedicated themselves to improving their
newspapers hiring outstanding editors
and giving them the money to build good
news rooms and all those papers are
improving in Portland and Cleveland and
New Orleans in New Jersey in a couple
days ago I brought with me the howard
kurtz story that in your own newspaper
what what job does Howard Kurtz have for
you Howie Howie Kurtz covers the media
for the Washington Post he writes about
your book by the way did you talk to him
about this he interviewed me he did the
story independently the way how it
operates because we have to make certain
that he can cover the Washington Post
objectively along with the rest of the
news business is that by and large he of
signs himself works with assignment or
who are out of the regular chain of
command so that we don't cause him to
write nice stories about us or stop him
from writing stories about our
shortcomings he says this I want to read
the whole paragraph he says it's unusual
newspaper executives Kaiser is now
associate editors that's Bob Kaiser who
wrote the book with you to assail their
own profession while in office rather
than from the safety of retirement when
you read that what was your reaction
well he's right my wife has been warning
me that there may be social gatherings
well be less popular in the future than
I was in the past as a result of the
parts of the book that are critical
about various various news organizations
but thanks to the support of Don Graham
the CEO of the Washington Post and beau
Jones that publisher the newspaper they
while they don't agree with everything
in the book because they look at
sometimes the things from or business
point of view than I do they supported
us in doing this book while I continued
to work at the paper and I should add
are the views in the book are ours alone
and not the Washington Post companies
even though I'm still working there well
your reporter hard Kurt says it doesn't
much criticized the post indeed the
authors say they are probably blind too
many of its shortcomings except for its
embarrassing failure to break the
iran-contra story what's that that was
during the Reagan administration when
they were swapping sales of arms to Iran
for the potential release of hostages
secretly and then using some of the
profits of that secretly to support the
Contra rebels in Latin America that were
fighting communist regimes there and all
this was done without telling the
American people without consulting the
Congress in fact some would argue in
violation of some of the restrictions
Congress had placed on aid to the
Contras and the this went on for a long
time without the news media knowing what
was going on and even when we began to
sniff around it and discover something
of what was going on we missed the main
story until a newspaper in the Middle
East's actually broke part of the story
that the exchange of arms for hostages
and then the Reagan administration
itself by predict knowledge publicly for
the first time that they had been
siphoning money off for this to pay for
the contrast that was not revealed by
the media we were slow to that story
Howard Kurtz writes the book but the
book sticks it to many news
organizations particularly the
television networks do you agree with
his account well I wouldn't like to say
it sticks it to it in fact some people
have noticed that we this is not just an
attack on his way
organizations that we don't think are up
to snuff but rather tries to examine
from the inside and take our readers
inside them to understand how they
actually work and to see both their
strengths and the shortcomings and we do
conclude that Network News has been
declining and quality steadily over the
last few decades and at the same time
the audience of the evening network news
programs has been declining also in fact
the book often drips with disdain for
electronic journalism most real news
down in keizer declare comes from the
newspapers well again I wouldn't that's
how is weird to staying I'm not
disdainful of the fine folks that I met
in in the television news however they
are working under very difficult
circumstances these days they have
relatively small news budgets most
people don't realize it for instance
here in Washington DC the WRC general
for local news operation owned by NBC
which is one of the best in the country
when the best local news operations in
the country has in any given time only
about 10 reporters covering Washington
on an average day The Washington Post
has more than 110 reporters covering
Washington on an average day so there's
no way that channel 4 can cover the city
adequately and yet it makes fifty
percent profits approximately every year
that sends back to NBC it seems to me
some part of that fifty percent profit
can be invested in giving that fine news
organization more reporters to cover the
news better how did you go about
interviewing the three commercial
network anchormen well Bob Kaiser and I
know all three anchors and we told them
about this book project we know that
they themselves are ambivalent about
what's happened to network news over the
last year's and are trying hard to keep
its standards as high as possible and
their particular shows so Bob had this
interesting idea of picking out
newscasts that one newscast for each to
anchor that they each done 20 years ago
not long after they had taken over their
anchor chairs it when the news looked
very different it was full of much more
serious news coverage now there were
more stories in each half hour news
because there are fewer commercials and
more that there's more foreign news
there was more national government news
more the reporters were beat reporters
that you know stayed in the same beat
day in day out nor experts on their
subjects than now so we show them those
each each anchor a tape of that
broadcast at the outset of our interview
and ask them to talk to us about what
change and it turned to be turned out to
be the great key to unlock their
feelings about what's been happening the
network knows and what how would you
characterize it you know in some cases
they thought that the changes were
inevitable because technology's changed
and life has changed the United States
in other cases they thought some of the
changes were good Tom Brokaw thinks that
the NBC focus on a lot of lifestyle and
medical coverage is a good change and
network knows but there also was
concerned expressed I think probably by
each one of them but particularly by Dan
Rather to some extent Peter Jennings
about the things we're missing from the
broadcast now particularly more foreign
news coverage and and and and serious
government coverage that people need in
order to be an informed citizens were
you at all surprised at what and I'm
going to read some of the quotes what
some of the things I said about their
own organizations well since I know them
individually I realize that they can
because they are outstanding news people
I know that they are sometimes
self-critical about the organization so
I wasn't entirely surprised but since
they were on the record what's going to
be in a book I wasn't certain that they
would be that Frank Peter Jennings is
talking about some of the shows like
ABC's 2020 and he says that these shows
to do some very good things but in he
goes on to say they now do too much of
the same thing they're very serious
bottom feeders and therefore a whole
chunk of the audience has just gone away
and gun other things Jennings said this
is what you write in the book he feared
that many of those viewers also quote
have left the evening newscast because
they're just fed up with television well
explained well first the news magazine
shows its so-called news don't know why
they're called news magazines they do
look like magazines but not necessarily
news magazines all three anchors clearly
were not pleased about them because they
called themselves news but in fact
they're mostly about celebrities and
crime and and relatively sleazy kind of
news coverage and and that bothered all
the anchors but it also bothered for
instance dan Rather that increasingly
network interest and resources is
shifting from the evening news to those
programs which are cheaper to produce
and therefore make more money and he can
discern a kind of impatience
with his bosses with the high cost of
still putting on the evening news and
you just read Peter Jennings quad he
doesn't really approve of these shows at
all doesn't really think of them as new
shows like his own news show did you ask
him why they participate in again rather
never really told us that he's obviously
as on as a host of 48 hours and which
often has the kind of news that he
wouldn't want to have on his own evening
news show and he never really did say
why why you continue to participate one
can imagine that when you're paid a good
sum of money by your network to do by
and large what they ask you to do that
you go ahead and do it each of them also
is still able to use their influence
however to make certain and in each year
they do put on shows that they really
want to put on Peter Jennings for
example has an agreement with ABC that
he gets to put on a certain number of
documentaries and town meetings and
other kinds of shows that he feels
contribute to public knowledge and and I
would the question we asked each of the
anchors is what happens after you're
gone maybe the Peter Jennings successor
won't have the kind of clout he has to
make certain he's able to put shows on
the air that he thinks are good for the
American people as well as two is to
edit his own news show the way that he
wants to what will happen after they're
gone and we didn't really feel we really
got a satisfactory answer for me any of
them obviously it's always hard to think
about your own succession and when we
talked to other people at the network's
they say well we're grooming you know
we're grooming other anchors and so on
but they don't have the same kind of
news backgrounds that these three
gentlemen have and I wonder what is
going to happen in the evening news when
they retire which so I probably will
happen in five to ten years because
they're reaching that age here's a quote
from dan Rather quote we have gone from
being the number one priority to being a
sort of a bastard child we cost money we
don't make nearly as much as the others
but you show some figures in here where
they were making as much as 300 million
dollars every year the the NBC News
Network itself makes hundreds of
millions of dollars all of NBC News but
that includes those magazine shows which
are low cost and high revenue the
evening news itself as a part of that is
probably not nearly as profitable
although the NBC Evening News probably
the most profitable has the highest
ratings but you would not surprise me we
don't know the internal figures
release them but would not surprise me
if the evening news and chefs shows
themselves are not making less money and
it's the magazine shows and the Today
Show in the morning on NBC that are
making the big bucks Tom Brokaw quoted
here is saying I'm still waiting for one
of those Washington talk shows to deal
with a fact right but again I mean these
you're talking about people that
participate in all these programs why
would they say that about their own
program well they don't participate in
the Washington talk shows obviously
other people on the network participate
in those and there might be some
disagreement then about their quality I
think that each of the anchors feels
that they are doing the most they can
within their sphere of influence in the
network to keep the news as high-quality
as possible Bob and I probably would
conclude that they don't succeed these
days as much as they succeeded in the
past because there is such pressure on
them to be popular to have high ratings
for their shows but you also point out
that they're their money that they get
has gone up and up you point out the dan
Rather when he started up two men and
it's now up to what nine or ten million
right this is a touchy subject with that
we ask each one of them if the high
salaries they're being pain doesn't take
away from money that could be invested
elsewhere in the news product and and
you know while they each thought that
they were you know they earn their money
they didn't disagree that that might be
a possibility but they didn't they don't
like talking about their own
compensation that much you write some
about Tim Russert and the way he does
make the press not the way he does meet
the press well yes I'm sorry is somebody
some part it when Tim Russert is asking
questions on Meet the Press he's
terrific he prepares himself well we
asked really good questions our concern
about Tim Russert is the other aspects
of what happens to a big television news
personality like that the the
expressions of opinion that sometimes
come through on those talk shows by him
or the way in which he who we might
bring on the show like Matt Drudge who I
don't really regard as a real journalist
or the ways in which in his conduct for
instance of the presidential debates he
would insert himself and he is agenda
into the
into the news making himself a focus of
the news now Tim strongly disagrees with
this we we let him as well as the other
people we write at length about in the
book see what we wrote about them before
publication and he feels were being
unfair in in in pointing those things
out which I think actually makes our
point that when you become such a big
star it is hard to remain a news person
aside an observer on the side as opposed
to a performer yourself which I think
tim has become you bent the post in 64
so you have you were there during
Watergate and then you were there during
the movie All the President's Men what
role did the Washington Post play in the
celebrity journalism team Bob Woodward
car burns well I I don't think we
thought this out and in fact Ben Bradlee
would tell you that it was kind of
amazing to him and he has some almost
regrets about it but yes certainly the
the celebrity achieved by Bob Woodward
and Carl Bernstein and the post
particularly through the movie for all
the movie All the President's Men and
the whole Watergate story has a high
said a large role to play in the
celebrity patient of journalists since
then page 2 40 in your book you write
this declining television coverage of
politics and government dragged down the
country's civic life voters had less
information when they went to the polls
national and local politicians complain
bitterly that it was impossible to
discuss important issues or launch
serious new ideas on broadcast
television because the networks and
stations had no vehicles other than
Sunday morning talk shows that permitted
extended discussion of political or
policy topics when the medium that most
Americans rely on for news reduces its
coverage of government and politics
government officials and politicians can
safely conclude that the country is
paying less attention to them and to
what they are doing that can easily lead
them to misbehave I think that's a very
very serious problem when you watch the
network news and local television news
during a campaign you may see the
glitter of the campaign they the via
performances that the politicians want
that they seen on television and the
backdrops that they want to have see be
seen on television but in terms of
serious discussion of the issues and
serious questioning
politicians about their stands and the
issues very little that takes place
anymore on network television or local
news they do vote very little time to
political and government coverage and so
instead i think that the voters primary
impression of the campaign from washing
television comes from the ads which the
the networks and particularly local
stations most of its sold a local bought
by locusts local sold by local stations
to the politicians the ads are
everywhere during the advertising
portions of the show bringing a lot of
money to the stations but by their very
nature the ads are misleading and and
and very negative and I think create a
distorted impression of the campaign for
the people watching them that is not
balanced they're offset in any way by
sufficient news coverage on those
stations what but what about the chicken
and egg problem a lot of these
candidates won't even submit to
questions on television anymore I think
if television it well television can
still go out and cover what they say and
their public utterances television can
still do stories about the issues in the
campaign they can go out and talk to
voters and do all the things that back
newspapers are doing particularly the
larger metropolitan daily still when
they cover a campaign does it have to be
done on the three commercial television
networks that have been around from the
beginning of television or can it be
done on cable it certainly can be done
in cable into a great extent the three
television networks seed more political
coverage the cable all the time most of
the coverage of the political
conventions for instance now takes place
on cable and Andy lack at NBC will tell
you oh we cover the conventions but it's
on MSNBC not and NBC which would be fine
except for the fact that still the more
many more Americans watch NBC than watch
MSNBC I may change over time but it
means that only a small minority of
Americans are being exposed to a lot of
this political coverage right now and
local television stations are still a
primary place people go for local news
and it's after all elections are more
important locally the nationally even
with those local candidates for local
office and for Congress and so on and
for state government and that is where
the coverage is the least the three
television networks covered the National
Campaign give more time to that coverage
than local stations give the local
campaign 85 million people in this
country have cable or satellite and it's
a matter of flipping the dial from NBC
over to
something else why is it that what's the
responsibility there who's why does NBC
have a responsibility to keep giving you
more and more politics right over here
on challenge well the you know the
viewers are watching the network's
because that's what entertainment shows
are and the sports shows that they like
to watch that's the currently the
condition you know that may gradually
change over time HBO for instance taking
some entertainment off audience away and
so on but as long as the networks are
presenting and the local television
stations are presenting news programs on
the air I believe they should cover the
news thoroughly and responsibly the way
all the news organizations do and if
there's competition from cable for that
coverage fine now give that will give
viewers more choices as you're as you're
saying but they make a lot of money from
those news shows they should present a
full coverage of the news when do you
think the American people were served
the best buy the news business well we
certainly have seen it since September
11th beginning on September levis shows
it shows how the media can perform at
its very best the network news shows
covered the events of September 11th and
and the impact of them over the next
several days continuously without
interruption by commercials without
interruption by entertainment programs
the after having pulled back most of
their foreign correspondence from abroad
they sent people back out again to cover
the story in the field they've done a
very good job of covering the terrorism
and the wars in September 11th a new
chain owned newspapers that had not been
devoting very much new space to national
or foreign coverage added space to
newspapers for this coverage I think we
saw the news media at its best
immediately after September 11th I'm
afraid we're now seeing people going
back to the news organizations going
back to previous habits now most of that
extra space has gone from newspapers a
lot of the morning television coverage
in particular has gone back to
relatively frivolous stuff celebrity
news and cooking and fashion and so on
and away from serious news again and to
some extent the evening news shows the
balance also seems to be shifting back
to two more to to less serious news
coverage than we saw at the height of
the coverage of September 11 what's your
suspicions as to why people are by
either people in the news business or
Ezra with people in the public aren't
watching sorry I'm not sure that you
know if you can't you talk about chicken
and egg earlier if you're not if you're
not given good serious news coverage to
watch it can't watch it certainly there
is a belief in the people that run
television news organizations and many
newspapers that people are no longer
interested in serious news coverage and
there may have been some debt to some
extent before September 11 people had
forgotten how interconnected they were
with the rest of the world and had
forgotten that there are economic and
other problems to be attended to in this
country however I'm not certain that
that interest in serious news when as
low as the people run many news
organizations thought it had i mean i
i've talked for instance in the book
about my own decisions about the the
untimely death of John F Kennedy jr.
certainly a dashing interesting
celebrity figure but not somebody want
his own it accomplished anything in
public life wasn't really contribute
anything particular to the country and
yet his death was treated as top of the
front page news in all newspapers
including ours I mean I went along with
the flow as I look back on it I think
that was a disservice to our readers I
should have been somewhere on the front
page people interest in it but should
have been in proportion to the other
serious news was occurring at that same
time so we can't just blame the audience
for things we can't just say they all
they don't want to see for knows dan
Rather tolls he wasn't allowed to use
the word foreign on the air anymore
because it would be a turn-off to his
audience well I just don't believe that
it seems to me that if you are
presenting serious news in an engaging
way people will pay attention to it if
you point out to them that when most of
their cars and appliances are made
overseas and when a number of American
jobs have gone overseas because of
what's happening to the world economy
there are ways to make international
news for example interesting and
important to people but go back to the
television thing after all these years
there used to be only three networks and
now there are a couple hundred choices
and a lot of people abandon the networks
and the news what what is it the public
sees that we don't see well I think I
think the public is seeing when I see
serious news choices and other choices
of special interest to them all sports
channels all financial news channels etc
that certain parts of the public will
follow their special interests off two
to one of the two one of the new cable
alternatives
the mass audience is still however with
the major networks and with over
broadcast stations even though they
receive them on gable that still is
where they spend a majority of their
television watching time so I think
there's still a serious responsibility
there to cover the news well now over
the years ahead it may be the cable will
change this balance and that you know
these other choices will be more robust
for people we one caveat with that
though is that so far the cable
organizations cannot yet afford the news
organizations to cover the news as well
as the broadcast networks automated
probably cNN has the largest number of
resources but it's still unable to cover
the news in the same sophisticated
fashion as the broadcast networks
networks do the what I like about cable
television is how often it will break
out of whatever its set programming was
to be to show you a news event as it's
going on now sometimes it's trivial
stuff that and that bothers me you know
some shooting of two people somewhere in
Kansas and they're following in a
helicopter they're following some police
cars around but there are a lot of other
significant things particularly as we've
seen some September the 11th
presidential press conference Pentagon
briefings things going on in Afghanistan
and and so on where the fact that they
will devote air time to showing you the
news as it actually occurs which the
network's the major networks cannot
afford is a real service the American
people what's your dream when it would
come to television though in news what
do you think they should do I I would
think that they ought to be able to
devote more resources to news coverage
hire more reporters with more expertise
in the subjects they're covering and do
a better job of covering the broad
expansive news that they ought to be
covering obviously on a national level
for the networks and local communities
for local television and i do not see
the changes caused by cable changing the
world soon enough that that isn't
necessary for the networks and local
television station to do and we we we
saw some local television news
operations around the country then do it
better that do not always leave the news
every night with the latest murder that
do not insist that every
reporter has to be live on the street in
front of an empty courthouse building at
eleven o'clock at night but rather use
that reporter time and actually
reporting another story to present the
viewers and those organs organisms
television stations have good audiences
we found for instance that some of the
best tell local television news had
audiences just as large as some of the
worst of local television know so you
can't tell me that audiences don't want
good local news I don't remember the
figures exactly maybe you can help me
that WRC the local station here you save
made something like 120 million dollars
sometime remember the exact figure
either but yes tens over 100 million
nine News yes yes and that they are
losing audience yes they are yeah what's
the message here well I think the
message is well turn to Bob long we we
quote the book he's the news director of
WRC television a good one who told us
that he went to his NBC bosses after
September 11th and said we have a lot of
new viewers now actually viewing went up
after September 11th after this decline
he said a lot of our young viewers and
they're not necessarily going to stay
with us because they don't have the
habit of watching local news but they've
been watching it now because something's
going on that matters to them give me
the resources to cover more of the
important news like we're covering this
story so we can hold on to those viewers
and we're waiting to see if he's going
to have more resources and be able to
improve his coverage as a result why do
you think that the young people are
reading less watching less news seem to
care less about it what is it about
their generation that maybe you don't
know I think there I think there are
many different circumstances there
certainly are many more things competing
for their time not just news media
entertainment media all those channels
on television everything that's
available on the Internet video games
just so much more to occupy young
people's time nowadays and their world
is faster they grew up with computers
and MTV everything moves faster for them
their attention spans are shorter to
some extent what's interesting is
however is that they're beginning to
read more news on the internet at at
times like 911 they are watching more
news on Television reading more news in
the newspaper there are certain subjects
not surprisingly subjects like
employment and technology that are
important in there
lives that they do come to the news
media for so I think it to some extent
it is beholden on us to make certain
that we're providing them the news
coverage that they need and the format's
that they will watch and listen to in
order to attract them to the news media
I i I'm still optimistic about them and
and and their interest in news as they
as they grow older and I think that one
of the good developments is the Internet
the news organizations like all the
networks and all the major newspapers
and local newspapers are able to provide
on the on the computer where these young
people live lively interesting news
presentations now on our new sites and I
and that is beginning to attract younger
people and I think that might be a way
to bring them into news as they grow
older what's accountability reporting
accountability reporting is holding the
many people and organizations and
institutions in our society that have
power over the rest of us accountable to
us we're talking about government
obviously big corporations big charities
like the Red Cross after September 11th
we discovered that the Red Cross had
collected more blood than it knew what
to do with it had a throw it away which
is really sad for the people that
thought they were contributing their
blood to a good cause they collected all
this money that people were showering on
the Red Cross with hopes that it would
be properly used for the victims of the
terrorist attacks and initially there
was a lot of confusion over what was
going to happen to that money well the
Washington Post led the way in writing a
lot of stories about what the Red Cross
was up to and they made changes they
made changes in their in their
organization and changes in the way in
which they've been handling their
donated blood and their donated money as
a result of that coverage we held them
accountable to the people that
contributed that money and that blood
that's accountability reporting bill
o'reilly will tell you on his program
that he's responsible for
single-handedly responsible for forcing
lee a red cross to move along with their
contributions to the people that you
know were killed and the families left
over September the 11th he may well have
contributed to it I I did not see that
particular show or know where that's
fitting with our coverage but probably a
number of news organizations were
responsible because when when in this
competitive world
when you notice somebody's reporting
something that looks like it's important
you'll want to get into that reporting
to and I know for instance the New York
Times didn't good stories about the
fundraising for the victims in New York
of the World Trade Center about crash
you write about the story that the New
York Times did Doug France the story on
this church of scientology is that one
that you actually wrote or did bob
kaiser right that I by Bob Kaiser wrote
that particular passage in the book but
I know all about it cuz we rewrote each
other all the way through the book and
by the way how long did it take you to
write the book itself the research and
the writing took us about two years
because we did it in addition to our day
jobs and when you actually got down to
writing it or did where did you write it
we each wrote it in our home computers
and we would then trade chapters back
and forth so I write a Chad craft of a
chapter give it to Bobby rewrite it give
it back to me and I'd say well some of
this looks good but some of us i don't
like i rewrite it again till we finally
arrived at a draft of each chapter that
we liked among other things that meant
that the book had the same voice all the
way still even though two of us were
working on it do you still have a
disagreement left after all your
discussions about what not really there
might be a few tiny things here and
there I think that Bob probably has had
more pessimistic about the future the
news media than i am i'm a tad more
optimistic well back to the Church of
Scientology what was that story and why
did you include in your book we included
in our book because it was not a story
that brought about great change we
didn't want to have all the we wanted to
put in the book a lot of examples for
our readers of journalism it makes a
difference that news matters as we say
in the book and we wanted to give an
example of one we couldn't say somebody
went to jail somebody's life was saved
some money was sage or something like
that but yet nevertheless people's
knowledge about an important subject was
increased what happened here was that
the Church of Scientology after many
years of pushing the IRS to classify it
as a church and therefore give it a
charitable exemption under IRS laws
finally succeeded in having it happen
and we and nobody found out why the the
Church of Scientology is not thought to
be a church by some people thought to be
a church by others but the struggle had
with the IRS was it was quite
interesting but most of them had taken
place in secret this
the intense lobbying that it that it had
with the with the IRS some people might
say and harassed the IRS until the IRS
made the decision that it wanted but at
any rate this was an important story
that hadn't been reported very much was
kind of a secret settlement that the IRS
just suddenly announced and didn't talk
about what they did so here we had two
organization the Church of Scientology
and internal revenue service that are
very important in our society probably
little is more powerful than the IRS and
and the Church of Scientology is
certainly a significant presence in this
country and and both of them are
relatively secretive they don't like
they don't like having themselves
reported on very much and together they
did something that is newsworthy and so
the New York Times the reporter there at
the New York Times Doug France and his
editor Dean Beck aid and then National
out of New York Times is now the
managing out of the Los Angeles Times I
decided to try and find out what
happened there and produce the story
that showed a great deal of what had
happened there and even though it didn't
change the IRS and how they were going
to handle this particular case or how
they were going to deal with secrecy
generally and it didn't change the
Church of Scientology's approach to its
to its exemption or make it any more
revealing about its internal workings
people knew something important about
these institutions that they hadn't
known before one of the things that I
kept feeling as i read that is that both
the church of scientology and IRS if
they don't want to tell you something
it's hard to get it out of extremely
difficult and they're not the only
institutions like this in American
society but there are two very good
examples of very secretive organizations
that make it very difficult to find out
what goes on inside them why didn't the
IRS have to tell you the rationale for
making them the tax laws are written in
such a way that there's a great deal of
privacy that properly is according to
American taxpayers that the IRS uses is
its reason for not telling us very much
of what they do Jon Kerley wouldn't talk
to you well we sent letters to Jon
Kerley who runs the Gannett news
organization that owns many newspapers
across the country and many television
stations and to Tony Ritter who runs
night river which also owns a great deal
from a great many newspapers across the
country and the book is critical of
what's happened to newspapers under both
ownership and so we sent letters to each
of them saying we're doing this book we
focus a lot of a ten
news organizations we'd like to
interview about it and Tony night said
yes and we had an interview in which he
disagreed with a lot of our findings but
because his reactions are in the book
and curly did not respond is that
unusual for somebody who runs another
major news organization not to talk to
somebody from the Washington Post um I
have to say it's relatively unusual I
mean I'm not you normally engaged in
that Howie Kurtz normally yes but i
think it's relatively unusual do you
know him yes I do yes I do and so you've
never talked to him about this no no I
don't know him that well we haven't seen
each other since we began working this
book you know that the Gannett is is
headquartered in the Washington DC area
and therefore it's one of our local
companies that we cover and they're not
always pleased with the Washington Post
coverage of their company either on the
cover of this book you have a lot of
news organizations that you mentioned
I'll show the audience what the cover
looks like it's hard to see it unless we
get really up close there is one
organization that is missing from the
cover I want to ask you about and that
is the Washington Times Oh any reason
why they're not on there no I the book
covers all news organizations so there's
hundreds that could have appeared on the
cover their newspapers television
organizations and so on and exactly was
the publisher who decided which news
organizations to list on the cover we
don't discuss the times much if that if
at all like the respect for that they
may not be the that x is a special kind
of publication it's owned by a church
the Unification Church and it is a
relatively small audience and you know
there are many many newspapers around
the country that aren't named in the
book and that's one of them what role do
you think they play in this town I they
are avowedly a conservative newspaper
they believe that's their mission to to
represent a conservative point of view I
think that as a result a lot of their
reporting energy goes into reporting
that sphere of politics and and national
security affairs and so on and for that
audience I think they are kind of like a
newsletter for for what's the greatest
interest to conservative readers I think
that's probably a primary function and
time if you if that was the only
newspaper that you read would you be
reading a good newspaper I'm not going
to characterize whether it's good or bad
but
it's a newspaper that because of its
relatively small staff can only cover so
much it has relatively few local
reporters relatively few sports
reporters for example and it's a
newspaper as i said in covering
international and national affairs as a
point of view so it would be more like
being in britain where most of these
papers there are representing certain
point of view in the political spectrum
and you can't read just one of them if
you want to be well informed you have to
read a number of them across the
political spectrum and the washington
times fits into that kind of pattern you
other than referring to his novel you
don't talk much about what jim lehrer
does and he gives us an hour a day of in
death news now I don't know what their
audiences but it's relatively small
compared to the the big networks but
people could watch that if they wanted
to it's there every night yes why don't
you you know why don't they watch more
of it if they want in depth well I we
should have said more about the NewsHour
in the book because of very fine news or
new news show and in fact we concentrate
a lot on NPR in the book which is a
comparable news organization on radio as
opposed to television and I think that's
because we're focused on NPR as a news
organization doing a very good job
without without commercial pressures we
didn't also mention PBS in the NewsHour
more than we did but it's it but it's
similar it's a it's a good news
organization it's limited in its size
but he focuses the show well on those
things that they can do well for
particularly national affairs very very
strong on national government and
national politics and its audience is
sizable in fact in many nights as jim
has pointed out to me personally their
audience exceeds that of any of the
individual cable networks news programs
why still more people don't watch this i
think what i said earlier which is that
the networks the three major networks
are now increasingly fox have the
entertainment programs in the sports
programs that bring people those
networks to begin with and despite the
fact we all have our little clickers and
can change channels easily we're
creatures of habit and we tend to watch
the news that comes on the network as
entertainment programs for watching and
the entertainment and public affairs
programs on PBS appear to have a more
smaller audience however it's a very
influential audience their audience is
undoubtedly higher edgy
nated than the average audience and so
it's good that they have a good news
show to turn to you point out that NPR's
all things considered when you break it
down has thirteen thousand words in a
90-minute program your newspaper has 110
thousand words in a day and the New York
Times 105,000 words in a day how did you
go about finding all out I think I was a
hundred thousand we say her intent for
the post I think I'd be surprised if we
were in the Argonaut intent oh okay I am
surprised with more words in the New
York Times maybe with the day of the
week we pick but we're about to say you
there's a there's a way of counting
words that the Bob Kaiser tapped into
somebody coming keeps track of this and
he he went to that source what's that
mean though if if you if you listen to
all things considered for 90 minutes and
get 13,000 words and you read The
Washington Post I mean but there's a lot
of ways Mourinho hundred thousand words
in the Washington Post and you're right
because their sports in there there's
fashion their style there's a health
there's business news and so on so we
don't expect that anybody's gonna read
the entire paper from cover to cover
right there must be very few people at
the time to do that for the Washington
Post in New York Times because it would
take you hours and hours instead people
read selectively for the things that
they want to find that particular day of
greatest interest to them and then leave
through the newspaper it's a great thing
about a newspaper you can leave through
it and spot something that interest you
if you're listening to radio or watching
television you've got to wait and wait
for the thing that interests you and you
might be wasting those other minutes or
turn the station because nothing
interest you in the newspaper your
complete control it's one of the reasons
why don't expect newspapers to disappear
anytime soon despite all the new media
that have come along because you have
this unique experience being able to
leave through that newspaper and glanced
at the things that might interest you
slightly read intensively the things
that you want to read intensively it's a
unique way of approaching the news go
back to a comment you made earlier about
Matt Drudge you said that he is not a
journalist right what is he uh well he's
these two things he's a gossip and and
and in his heyday when he really focused
attention on this in his early days way
back in the 90s he would pick up some
juicy gossip primarily from newsrooms he
had sources inside newsrooms and found
out what newspapers were reporting on
now and would try to beat them to
publication by putting a a snippet of
this rumor on his website before it
appeared in the newspaper
and as a result sometimes as rumors were
accurate and sometimes they were
completely wrong and one of the worries
i had is that people would go to a site
and not know this now people I think I
understand this about Drudge would
frequently see things that were quite
wrong and believe that they were true
and you know go through the rest of
their day thinking this thing was true
or was false because George was wrong
the second thing he's become is a link
service he scans through everybody
else's online news organizations and
picks out the the stories that he thinks
would be of greatest interest to the
people that come to the Matt Drudge
Report and actually in that way he's a
benefit to the washington post company
because he he frequently links up to
goods goods good stories on
washingtonpost.com and he's one of the
chief sources of traffic to Washington
Post com which I know he likes because
when he spotted that we said that in the
book he actually put that up on his site
yesterday is a fact why why does the
Washington Post put its material on the
web internet free because right now
people expect things on the internet to
be free by and large unless it's a
special service being performed for them
so no news organizations except the Wall
Street Journal have succeeded or tried
so far to charge for news on the web the
journal is able to do it I believe
because they bundled their web
subscription with their paper
subscription and people are able to
write business people are able to write
that off as a business expense so
they're much much more likely to pay
that fee to use something on the web the
historically the web culture has been a
culture of expecting things to be free
in the web i think that's gradually
changing though and i wouldn't be
surprised somewhere down the road to see
some kind of subscription model begin to
come along but if you remember the web
only new site tests late actually the
commentary site more than a new site for
a while did charge a subscription and
found that it it's a readership went way
down people are unwilling to pay for it
and so they had to go back to being free
you say though that a newspaper makes
between twenty and forty percent of its
revenues from classified quite indeed of
its advertisements right average
advertised yes it does and that the
internet starting to get into this but
that's right what happens that if you
all by using the internet putting your
material on there began to get people to
use it a lot and then you lose the
revenues with your big favor that would
be one way to look at it and the other
way to look at it is if they come to our
internets
for that classified and for news and for
the advertising we put up on it they're
still in the Washington Post family and
they're still reading Washington Post
news and in fact on the internet we have
gained hundreds of thousands of readers
for the Washington Post the ink on paper
newspaper only circulates in the
Washington area with a few copies going
to New York and some other places but
the Washington Post com website is
available throughout the United States
and throughout the world and we have
gained hundreds of thousands of new
daily readers of The Washington Post on
that website and I'm happy about that I
want people to read our news and if and
if people want to see classified
advertising in the web they can find it
on washingtonpost.com the question will
be as we come out of this recession and
as classified advertising us Help Wanted
advertising begins growing again is
there are more jobs to offer to people
how much of that is going to come back
to newspapers along with the web or will
most of it be on the web that's the big
question facing news newspapers right
now and we don't know the answer to it
yet you write the proliferation of news
outlets has shrunk the audience of each
one and weakened the commercial
domination of individual newspapers and
television stations and networks so
their owners and managers have been wary
of increasing their investment in news
coverage or risking unpopular journalism
they gave it also leads to a lot of
discussion your book about money and
Marge what is the margin for the
Washington Post uh it's in the
neighborhood of twenty percent each year
sometimes it's higher sometimes it's
lower depending upon the how good the
advertising sales are that year
newspapers generally average around
twenty to thirty percent profit margins
and sometimes higher local television
stations average forty to fifty percent
profit margins and sometimes higher that
makes those really good businesses in
terms of profits compared your average
business your average manufacturing
company is very happy to make five to
ten percent profits and as a result I
think the news media have room to spare
and their profit margins I want the post
to be very profitable that is what pays
for high quality journalism I want other
news organizations to be profit enough
to pay for high quality journalism but I
want them to plow some of those profits
back into the newsroom as the Washington
Post does and I'd like to see more
newspapers do that when her block her
block died
a couple months ago it was revealed that
he had 50 million dollars that he had
made over the years at the Washington
Post he actually had made that money as
a salary at the Washington oh I mean was
my god yes he was he'd been at the post
for a half century and in the early
years many people don't realize that in
1933 the post was bought at bankruptcy
by eugene meyer Catherine Graham's
father the late catherine Graham's
father the grandfather of Donald Graham
now the CEO of the paper and for many
years he had to subsidize the paper out
of his own pocket he was a very rich
manan seer tens of millions of dollars
he plowed into the newspaper before it
became for broke even much less made a
profit and during that time one of the
ways in which he could compensate
somebody like her block who was already
an outstanding talent in the early days
of the grahams family's ownership of the
paper was to give him stock that then
wasn't worth much but over the years as
the post then became profitable as it
bought up a competing morning newspaper
and as the afternoon newspaper went out
of business and it became the dominant
newspaper in Washington it was very
well-run it made large profits and its
stock price went up and that's where
herbes fortune came from let me give you
a bunch of things you've heard before
and asked you to explain why there
should be special First Amendment
treatment for newspapers this television
station when his television network when
people listen they hear 50 million
dollars that somebody generated in stock
over these years all the protection you
have the First Amendment the anchorman
in New York making ten million dollars a
year and you're sitting here saying we
need better news better for news and all
that and public out there saying look I
want my Matt Drudge Matt dredge to me is
truth more than it is at the Washington
Post tell us why we should listen to
what you're saying about this versus
that somebody that's getting the other
side somewhere else first of all I
strongly believe in the First Amendment
and the First Amendment makes it
possible for anybody in this country at
all to give anybody else news absolutely
and Matt Drudge is just as well
protected by the First Amendment's the
Washington Post and I want it that way I
don't want anybody messing with Matt
Drudge in that sense on the other hand I
think consumers should be well informed
just as you ought to know whether the
cereal you're eating really does have
vitamin C in it you ought to know
whether the news you are reading is as
good a news as it can be or let
too and in the case of Matt drudges
track record is that he doesn't really
report very much news himself and quite
often the rumors he reports are wrong
and then the rest of it is linking onto
somebody else's notes if you like that
fine but I just want you to know what it
is whereas the news that you read in The
Washington Post or the new york times or
the wall street journal the LA Times the
Raleigh News & Observer are produced by
staffs have really fine news people
working to certain high standards making
certain that their reports are accurate
and fair every day and dig dig as deeply
as they can and I want people to know
that's what that news is like and then
you can choose for yourself what kind of
news you want to read now these news
organizations should be profitable they
need to be profitable to pay for
printing presses and the salaries of all
those people and the high cost of
newsprint and television the case of
what you paid for all that technology
but I am but I am saying that the
profits are high enough that more of
that money ought to be devoted to news
coverage not necessarily to the high
salaries for anchors and her box a
special case in the saucony guy when you
work at a place for 50 years and its
stock has gone from nothing to something
you would expect to have some money out
of the stock that was given two years
ago there aren't many 50 million people
50 million dollar people at the
Washington Post I can tell you that are
we better off as a country having the
news more fragmented than it is now more
fragment and it was 20 years ago yeah
why it's taking us through a transition
because having more choices is always
better having more choices always best
with the free society is about that's
what capitalism is about having as many
choices as possible then you choose the
best thing however we're going through a
transition period in which we may not be
well off better off necessary right at
this moment because some of the new news
organizations are not yet don't yet have
the experience and the depth to
necessarily present the news as well as
they could and some of the old news
organizations have been shaken by all
this competition is fragmentation and by
losing audience and by losing
advertising and so they need to find
their way to this new to this new
parameter and one of the things that I
think could be could happen or a couple
things we talked about the books the
profits could be somewhat less modest
than they are and they are now so what
left large and they are now somewhat
more modest so they are now and yet
still turn a very handy return for
stockholders in these companies and put
more money into news into news coverage
and and also that the consumers and the
news organizations owners can look at
the best news organizations in this
country the ones that spend the most
money on news and they're also the most
profitable so there must be something it
must be something good about producing
good news it says in the back that you
took some money from pew for a
researcher and for travel yes and pew
also is the ones funding the Civic
journalism are you a big fan of civic
journal now I'm not a fan of civic
journalism again I I think that there's
no reason to stop people from trying to
improve news and some people believe
some people in academia and some people
in journalism believe that Civic
journalism is one way to improve the
news certain aspects Civic journalism
that try to sum up quickly is a belief
that news organizations need to cover
public affairs more but also need to
essentially force Americans to get more
involved in public affairs the first
part of it I totally agree with cover
Public Affairs more cover elections
better don't just cover the horse race
cover the real issues find out what
interest the voters that's part of civic
journalism it's also part of good
journalism I agree with that but the
other aspect of civic journalism is make
sure people vote make sure that people
decide if they need a new Civic Center
downtown make sure that people are going
to do something about poverty and the
poorest neighborhood in town those are
all nice things and proper objectives
for people in society but that's not
what news coverage is about news
coverage should not be designed towards
achieving certain desired ends that's
biased news coverage and that's wrong
our guest has written this book with Bob
Kaiser he is the top editor at The
Washington Post has been there since
nineteen sixty four and as a native of
Cleveland Ohio and the book is called
the news about the news thank you very
much thank you